fans of yet to catch a glimpse are Hulk
in any Avengers and game footage but
promotional materials have made their
way online and made it plain as day Hulk
is coming back but how a new toy leak is
spilling the details revealing something
major about Hulk's arc in the film
action figure photos that were recently
leaked show hulks ultimate form in
action with the newly confident
superhero sporting all the Brawn of the
big green guy with what certainly looks
like the intellect of Bruce Banner or
wrapped up in one of the Avengers fancy
new suits but that's not the only leak
of Hulk's new form another photo of the
packaging for a different Titan heroes
Hulk action figure by Hasbro shows
Hulk's suited up in the same silvery
white red and black uniform that his
fellow Avenger sported in the latest
endgame trailer which many have
theorized to be related to the bulky
quantum suits last seen in ant-man and
the wasp most importantly the text
accompanying the drawing details the
circumstances that will lead to banner
becoming this all-new version of the
Hulk Bruce Banner masters his temper to
become the giant super-strong hero
Hulk that's a little bit different from
the way we're used to hope doing things
that's my secret Kevin
I'm always angry
the idea that banner has to master his
temper again to be able to go green in
endgame is intriguing building on the
emotional trauma and fear halt displayed
after Thanos
well hog belt on him and infinity war so
it makes sense ends game could feed
Shabana getting a grip on his temper in
order to become not just the Hulk but
professor Hall an elevated version of
the character from Marvel Comics law if
successfully fusing the brains of Bruce
with the might of Hulk is what it's
going to take to bring the big green guy
back maybe that's why he hasn't been
seen in any endgame footage yet it'd be
a pretty natural end game for the
characters arc as well after all he's
been getting a lot better at talking
things through over the years this is
what friends do they support each other
your burners friend friend for you
really don't even like burner if you're
unfamiliar with this particular twist on
the character walk break things down for
you
professor Hulk isn't a Hulk that
completed a doctorate degree instead
he's a merged form of Bruce Banner a
poor human scientist whose exposure to
gamma radiation split his personality
the savage Hulk which is the Green Hulk
fans are most familiar with and the grey
Hulk the somewhat intelligent original
Hulk from the comics they call me mr.
Fixit introduced in 1991's Incredible
Hulk issue 377 professor Hulk is his own
entity not a cut and dry merger of the
three different Hulk personalities but
rather Bruce banners ideal self he
possesses banners intelligence savage
Hulk's super-strength and gray Hawks
cunning plus a more human face and an
ability to maintain power while keeping
his core however there's a catch if
professor Hulk becomes too angry but in
a piece of his will be broken leading
him to turn back into a Bruce Banner who
was anything but mild-mannered if
professor Hulk is something of a
scientist in Hulk's body then his
version of Bruce is basically the Savage
Hulk in human form that catch is
important to be aware of and the rest of
the backstory seems to tie into the
information included in this toy lake
the only way ends game could feature
professor Hulk as if Banner takes the
reins on his temper and keeps his
emotions in check if he can maintain the
balance he might just become the most
powerful version of himself he could
possibly be
Banner taking control of his anger and
end game would wrap up a three movie
for the character that began with four
ragnarok in 2017 according to Mark
Ruffalo Hulk speech evolution is a
crucial element of the characters
metamorphosis from Ragnarok and the
first sign that Banner and Hulk was
starting to separate from one another as
the actor played ear poke speaking is to
start - a separating of these two
individuals these identities in the
split identity person and where that's
going to end up going there are plenty
of unanswered questions Avengers ends
game will hopefully address not the
least of which is how and why banner
will Hulk out once again but thanks to
Ruffalo's comments that this purported
toy league and the sheer weight of fan
expectations were pretty confident it's
going to happen when he does show up
he'll likely be dramatically different
from how we've seen him before whatever
ends up happening to the big green dude
one thing seems undeniable he's probably
going to be far more important an end
game than anyone realizes check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about Marvel
movies are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]